for six months the country's been
watching a political Peep Show trying to
see underneath the government's brexit
strategy every utterance of the
cabinet's three main brexit ears Boris
Johnson Liam Fox and David Davis has
been ogle to work out which way they're
tilting Sky News has ventured across
Britain to their political power bases
in North Somerset the east riding of
yorkshire and west london to assess
voter confidence in their ability to
deliver our exclusive sky data research
reveals the British public is skeptical
about the government's progress so far
and its chances of cutting a good deal
with the EU a whistle-stop tour of the
three brexit ears constituency starts
here in uxbridge and south ruislip which
Boris Johnson has represented since the
last general election now it's a mix of
urban grit and leafy suburb as you can
see here was standing on the shores of
Little Britain lake this is one of the
few areas of the capital to opt for
brexit so how did the Foreign
Secretary's voters think he and his
cabinet colleagues have performed since
the result nightfly record spun into
existence last year owner david hurst
voted remain but he sees the flip side
we don't have a great deal with europe
then we have to try there's a big world
out there you know as we found out
through the shop pretty selling records
all over the world so hopefully we can
get better trade deals negotiate really
good trade deals with other countries
his son jack is a little less confident
bungled it frankly I mean or Boris
Johnson sort of it with being a major
sort of backer of it and then of
disappearing right afterwards visibly
aging for 20 years pretty much as the
vote went through you think your did he
what was the plan they didn't seem to
have a plan going into it really that
antipathy is replicated on a national
scale in our sky data poll only eleven
percent of people think the government
is doing a good job negotiating brexit
down the high street is the bustling
arcade cafe most here back to brexit
there's little
line of buyer's remorse the changes in
the last six months are scary you're
watching the euro you you know travels
affected everything is affected but
that's part of any in a way revolution
you've got to have scary things happen
so make things better so now I've no
regrets we've all got to sit back and
watch 200 miles north from there teeing
off at cottingham Parks golf and leisure
Holton price and howden is David Davis's
Yorkshire constituency these golfing
friends are split between leave and
remain but all believe the negotiations
will be arduous need a 27 countries to
make a decision you've never you have
never got 27 countries to agree on
anything you just want one of those 27
countries to veto any agreement and it
all falls to be exactly that's all
points which are great there are easy
Goodyear unico she a to this negotiating
a settlement this could be nearly
impossible you at the moment are happy
with the direction the government's
taking or need a very strong government
to get the best that oh and the question
I'm asking you is do you think that it's
a strong government I think that remains
to be seen they couldn't take it hard
bex it or soft brexit they haven't
indicated which way they're going on
that yet you would like more clarity yes
yeah definitely to the east of the
golfers is the Labour stronghold of hull
which also voted for brexit in this
historic city pub we find labour
supporting brothers who wanted Jeremy
Corbyn to deliver stronger remain
leadership and they don't expect an easy
ride from the EU no offense has up blame
the European Union for saying well there
hi what can you do
we've done a set yourself up for that
now when we're supposed to get all the
good bits and stir and remain separate
you can't do it it's thinking away
dennis is retired postman a pint
earmarked the end of his round he thinks
the Prime Minister is playing it well of
all the candidates who were up for the
job I think she was probably about the
best other yeah I'm quite happy The Wiz
things have started off this is a labor
constituency were in here Jeremy Corbyn
obviously the leader of the Labour Party
well how do you think he's done to be in
that position you've got to have
something about you don't think he has
there's something lucking there it
didn't come across to the Audrey among
industry job but nationally how do our
politicians stack up we asked would the
following politicians do a good job in
negotiating the terms of brexit forty
percent of people thought Theresa May
would do well twelve percent back Jeremy
Corbyn and twenty-seven percent of
people think Boris Johnson could get
Britain a decent deal from Northeast to
the southwest and the oldest continually
operated cinema in the world the kurzon
in clevedon north somerset
Colin Godfrey knows his MP the
international trade secretary dr. Liam
Fox well good doctor but he thinks
Theresa May strategy of no running
commentary means we are well placed to
secure a good deal after article 50 is
triggered and lots of legal industry and
business coming forward and shame yeah
we can make a go of it and more to say
more happening now in the country then
pre breaks so you're pretty optimistic I
am you come back in five years Richie
Lanz but that isn't reflected in a sky
data poll just twenty-two percent of
people think the government will get a
good deal when negotiations to leave the
EU are complete definitely in the latter
camp is Chris her self-described
socialist fishing off the town's
historic pier I think it's the worst
thing that's happened since World War
two I honestly do really yeah this
country I mean is this a nice country
but really I mean we want to be part of
other of a larger world really that's
the way I feel and you think some people
are pulling up the drawbridge I think so
yeah as this a step back with a 40 years
I think and sheltering in the cafe
Pauline and Barry Makai just returned
from living in Spain they see only
opportunities I think my one regret is
that I'm not 30 years younger unable to
to be out and part of it I think the
opportunities for Britain in the rest of
the world are enormous personally i
would i would get out much quicker than
planning I think actually they would get
a big shock because if they had a second
referendum making more people Brett said
because it wasn't as bad as they said
well whew i spoke to regretted their
decision there is still uneasiness about
the negotiation process ahead well our
poll suggests the government is failing
to please I believers who want a swift
exit or remain errs who of the brakes
applied waters ahead a far from tranquil
robinus with sky needs